what would you die for really you might
sacrifice yourself for the people you
love maybe your parents a younger
sibling your significant other maybe you
would choose to die if it meant that
your pet would live maybe you would die
for your country or for some principle
so crucial to the human project that you
trade your own existence to protect it
but would you die to ensure that future
Generations could take a bite of the
banana Dia that grows in the Andes would
you give your life for the enduring
survival of deus NAA faresi so that some
terminally neurolink hyper Zoomer a
century from now could suck on the
Himalayan Dead Man's finger or do you
believe so strongly in the prospects of
the American screw beam prus pube eskins
so that you'll trade your soul for the
remote change that it'll eventually be
harnessed to meet Humanity's fiber and
protein needs me I might consider dying
for the peanut butter tree because these
fruits seriously taste like peanut
butter but no probably not definitely
not you and I have not dedicated Our
Lives to protecting the largest and most
critical collection of biodiversity in
the world during one of the most
horrific periods of human suffering our
species has ever experienced and while
rats bread made of sawdust and even
other people were nutritional fair game
during the siege of lenrad the bnst at
The Institute of plant industry did not
eat the food they'd sworn to protect now
there are nearly 1,500 seed banks
worldwide including Norway's fbar
doomsday vault and the largest the
Millennium seed bank project in the
United Kingdom all preserving and
sustaining the world's plant life for
posterity this is the insane story of
the
first I briefly mentioned Nikolai
Ivanovich vlov in my 47-minute
documentary about the dangerous pseudo
science and terrible consequences of
trophy lenka's rejection of genetics
I'll link it in the description and give
you a chance to watch it at the end but
vov and his legacy are more than just
their battle with the failed dogma of
lism they're Their Own Story a story of
what science actually is and what
science means to our survival and to the
human Spirit Charles cber wrote in
National Geographic that Nikolai vov was
obsessed from a very young age with
feeding both Russia and the entire world
I was obsessed with Mario 3 vov could
have had a confrontational attitude
towards nature engaging in an epic
lifelong battle to draw from it enough
food to survive food that his father's
generation never seemed to have enough
of but tavlo nature wasn't the enemy it
was our most powerful Ally as long as we
never gave up trying to understand it
bov enrolled in the Petra skaya
agriculture Academy where he committed
to study and firmly learn the entire
4-year course in Just 2 years his
dissertation was called destructive
slugs of the fields and Gardens of
Moscow provinces and a vignette from
Peter Pringles the murder of Nikolai
vlov reveals how his life and mind were
seamlessly enmeshed with nature during
an official visit of the zarus Ministry
of Agriculture which ran the petka the
young student student was holding forth
on the subject of plant breeding when a
small green lizard crawled out of his
pocket and began climbing on his jacket
much to the amusement of his audience
Nikolai Ivanovich calmly picked up the
lizard folded it into his handkerchief
and put it back into his pocket the
handkerchief and jacket pocket are
actually significant here because even
when he was a student vof looked dashing
he dressed almost exclusive ly in
three-piece suits and was always well
groomed as if he committed to a
professional appearance out of respect
for the natural world once he was out of
school he worked for government agencies
as he traveled Europe to study plant
immunity and he also took a serious
interest in the rapidly developing field
of genetics in the 15 years since the
rediscovery of Gregor mle's work on
genetic inheritance the field had begun
to Boom worldwide and vov knew that
understanding genetics and learning
about the vast biodiversity in different
regions were the keys to knowing how to
get the most out of food crops he
learned English French and German during
his early travels which was crucial to
networking with the international
scientific Community vov was just 37
years old when he was appointed director
of the Lenin all Union Academy of
agricultural Sciences Vladimir lennin
was a strong believer in vavilov's work
and his approach to the increasingly
politicized field of science vov saw a
relationship between the Communist
Revolution and the Scientific Revolution
of the 20th century and he linked them
directly balov wrote without science we
cannot construct socialism it's hard to
know how much vov really believed in the
political Doctrine or whether he was
just playing the game because his Focus
wasn't on fueling a global proletariat
Revolution his Focus was on identifying
collecting cataloging and eventually
storing every seed in the world real
quick I hate paying for subscriptions
I'm not using if I want to see a show
I'll sign up watch it and then cancel
but with so many subscriptions I still
slip up and end up paying for stuff I
forgot about the sponsor of this video
rocket money helps with that it's a
personal finance app that helps you
cancel subscriptions lower bills and
manage your money better it'll clean up
subscriptions by safely and securely
identifying recurring charges and
cancels unwanted ones for you you can
even cancel from within the app with
just a couple of taxs no need to worry
about customer service calls rocket
money has helped save its customers an
average of
$720 a year with over $500 million and
cancelled subscriptions so join the over
5 million members use using rocket money
today go to Rocket money.com vau 2 or
click the link in the description to get
started for free you can also unlock
even more features with premium that's
rocket.com bsau 2 to get started for
free vavilov's obsession with collecting
seeds started in 1916 when he
encountered a variety of Rye in Northern
Iran That Grew over a meter high at an
elevation of more than 2,000 M when he
carefully plucked and bagged the rice
seed he added the first specimen to what
would eventually become a repository of
350,000 what VAV love would call his
world collection a vast seed bank that
could harness the world's Botanical and
biological diversity to selectively
improve seed strains in short it was one
of the greatest scientific undertakings
in human history vov truly was the the
Indiana Jones of seeds and he wasn't
concerned about whether something was
rare or exotic What mattered to him was
that it had a role in the ecosystem it
inhabited over a nearly 20e span vaav
went to Afghanistan the United States
Cuba Panama Peru China Japan Korea Spain
the entire Mediterranean abisinia and
Eritrea transcaucasus and turkey his
book five continents details all his
Expeditions from the first ride plucking
in Persia to his final jaunt in 1940 the
English translator describes his
comprehensive diary as ironic
mischievous perceptive hilarious and
above all scholarly he was active in the
international scientific community and
built an exceptional reputation so much
so that it was a problem his contacts
with the West raised suspicions and
eventually charges that he was an
international spy he just wanted to do
science and his report back from the
1932 6th International Congress of
genetics and selection in Ithaca New
York shows how detailed and thorough he
was did I mention vov loved collecting
seeds he loved collecting seeds he'd see
a plant out of the window of a car he
was riding in asked the driver to stop
and be out the door running into the
field while the car was still moving and
everywhere he went meant shipment upon
shipment back to the motherland whether
it was pallets of American corn
purchased with gold bullion from the
USSR or the endless stream of parcels to
add to the world collection but while
Lenin was a friend to vov Stalin was
hostile and when Farm collectivization
and Stalin's great turn resulted in
famines he blamed
vov you can go ahead and watch my video
on the scapegoat mechanism for details
on how that works Stalin thought that if
VAV science actually worked there
wouldn't be problems with feeding the
citizens so the science must be wrong we
know it's much more complex than that
but trophy lenka's magnificent promises
provided the hope of immediate relief
the long slow plotting and usually
boring science was out and betting on
instant Miracles was in on November 20
1939 Stalin summoned vlov to the Kremlin
near midnight he asked comrade vlov how
much longer will you go on fiddling with
your little flowers and such nonsense
who is going to increase our
agricultural output there was just not
really anything he could say to that he
did continue on with his work work
because his work was his life he had a
saying life is short we must hurry he
wasn't just the Indiana Jones of seeds
he was like also the Willy Wonka of
seeds impeccably dressed and energetic a
mix of light-hearted and deeply serious
and even Stalin himself couldn't make
him stop loving his world collection
vava was leading an expedition in West
Ukraine on August 6th 1940 when a black
car pulled up summoning him back to
Moscow on an urgent matter he was
arrested immediately and charged with
sabotaging Soviet Agriculture and
working in service of foreign
intelligence agencies Nikolai was
interrogated for more than a year Always
by a lieutenant named kavat and every
time it began like this who are you I am
the academic vavilov you are not an
academic you are a piece of
sh vafo gave lectures on biology and
genetics to other prisoners and that was
actually really common among the
scholars and researchers who were caught
up in Stalin's purges Alexander Solan
niten who was himself imprisoned
frequently mentions in the gulag
archipelago that Soviet Scholars kept
learning researching teaching and
working throughout their sentences but
VAV became a shell of the dynamic World
collector he once was and he finally
just broke he confessed by saying I
admit that since 1930 I have been a
member of an anti-soviet organization at
the heart of the ussr's Department of
Agriculture and that was that he was
sentenced to death by firing squad the
man who had spent his entire adult life
chasing every variation among the
world's seemingly endless biodiversity
from Kolkata to Cuba was set to Star
down a line of crude utilitarian
mass-produced
handguns vov sentence was reduced to 20
years but it didn't matter he died in
January of
1943 the man who made it his lifelong
mission to feed the world St to death or
he was thrown to his death into a pit of
lime just depends on who you ask fav was
dead but hundreds of thousands of his
seeds were still alive the problem is
that the Nazis were coming for them The
Institute of plant industry is still
located in Leningrad now St Petersburg
and The Institute staff of botanists
agronomists and researchers faced a
unique challenge throughout the Germans
872 day Siege of the city because seeds
not only require highly specific storage
conditions but they don't last forever
many have to be planted and reharvested
periodically how could the remaining
staff of The Institute possibly keep the
world's collection safe while Leningrad
was being raised to the ground with m
Ian dead and honestly why should they
and the Germans goal truly was to
eliminate Leningrad and its citizens a
military directive said requests for
surrender negotiations shall be denied
since the problem of relocating and
feeding the population cannot and should
not be solved by us we can have no
interest in maintaining even a part of
this very large Urban population it was
quite literally a fight to the death and
if that wasn't clear enough in a
November 8 1941 speech in Munich Adolf
Hitler said Leningrad must die of
starvation The Institute did have one
small Stroke of Luck SM alexanian and VI
kenko who told the Institute story of
The Siege in the journal diversity wrote
that it's location was near the German
consulate and the hotel at which Hitler
wanted to celebrate his victory with
such anticipation that he'd actually had
invitations printed in advance I should
mention it was cold there was no heat in
the Russian winter of the world's
northernmost large city the staff
boarded up Windows blown out by shock
waves and they burned whatever they
could to stay warm and to keep the seeds
from freezing as they kept 24-hour
surveillance over the collection they
hardly dug up potatoes from an
experimental field in nearby pavlus they
got them out just in time before the
Germans rolled in potatoes and other
tubers were especially a big problem
because they could be eaten eaten by
starving soldiers eaten by civilians who
had been reduced to eating sawdust and
shoe leather and dead bodies and eaten
by the researchers themselves they
Consolidated the collection from 40
rooms to 16 because it was easier to
guard they divided and packed up
shipments to sneak out of the city for
safety and redundancy and no one
absolutely no one was allowed to be
alone with any part of the collection
the staff of the institute for plant
industry wasn't just fighting the
Germans and the inhabitants of Leningrad
they were
fighting themselves and they were
starting to die AG stuchin a peanut
researcher died while sitting at his
writing desk stov kovaleski
Leoni Malaga coru they all starved to
death and it was still early 1942 The
Siege wasn't even a year old the ones
who barely remained alive were subject
to one of History's
cruestv and surrounded by food but their
mission was not to eat it DS ivanov's
professional Focus was rice so he
guarded the rice collection and when
they found him he was surrounded by
thousands of bags of rice grains that he
could have eaten to stay alive LM rodina
a junior research scientist in the
department of grain crops she died
surrounded by oats
they were just a few of the 28 employees
of The Institute who died during the
siege of Leningrad it can't be expressed
any better than what alexanian and kenko
wrote when they first brought this story
to the world the Soviet scientists chose
torment and death to preserve vav's
genan bank they all died so that tens of
thousands
of the most obscure seeds in the world
could live and through all the suffering
that the starvation of The Institute
staff in Leningrad balov himself
tortured and wasting away in The Saratov
gulg the continual press of the ver
mocked War Machine science
one the survivors embarked on a plan to
farm crops on several Acres near the
front lines of the fighting and it was
one of those plans that was so crazy it
actually worked documents after the war
also revealed that Hitler even had plans
to have a Commando unit raid the seed
bank it either fell apart or just never
came to pass so when The Siege was
finally lifted in January of 1944 the
institute's workers had successfully
reharvested the farmed SE seed snuck out
other seeds for preservation and guarded
what remained from Nazis hungry soldiers
desperate civilians and their own basic
human desire to stay alive they did it
for vov they did it for the world and
they did it for
science after the war The Institute
initiated a plan to regrow and reh
harvest everything in the world World
collection and they did it the Institute
celebrated its 75th anniversary in 1968
with a new name the vaval love Institute
for plant industry you can still visit
the Institute now they regrow about 10%
of their stored seeds each year and most
of the storage facilities haven't
changed in Generations when the USSR
renewed contact with the international
scientific Community people started
asking about FAO what what happened to
the man they knew and respected Stalin
dampened suspicion by appointing the
physicist Sergey valov nikolai's older
brother as president of the Academy of
Sciences of the Soviet Union when Serge
met with Stalin to receive the
appointment he asked what happened to
his brother Stalin pretended not to know
he made a phone call call during which
he likely feigned concern after he hung
up he told Serge to think they did away
with such a man as a university student
Nikolai vlov wrote in his diary that I
passionately want science I love it it's
the purpose of life only in science can
one experience
enthusiasm but vavilov's life of science
had one mortal
enemy Joseph Stalin and his contentious
everchanging politics of Soviet science
even though the man and the system have
succumbed to the Judgment of History
they swallowed up vov and they murdered
him in his academic Prime but Nikolai
vlov lived two lives one as a dashing
indefatigable Explorer of the world's
biodiversity of a man on a NeverEnding
quest to know the Earth's plant life and
to use it to feed the human race Stalin
may have extinguished that life but in
the other VAV swed a life of the mind so
that Humanity could reap its Legacy it
was a commitment to science and the
human project so deep that dozens of
people chose to die rather than derail
it and through that life Nikolai vlov
built a contribution to science one seed
at a time a body of work that survived
the German war machine the 20th
centuries most brutal dictator and the
ultimate struggle for survival and
because of that he is still
alive and as always life is short we
must
[Music]
hurry